the ccsd board of trustees could get  some outside assistance on team building  they'll discuss a professional learning  proposal from the nevada association of  school boards at their next board  meeting now the proposal has a price tag  of 8 500  and it includes things like a board  retreat individual coaching and self  evaluations  really looking at relationship building  conflict resolution  which is completely wrapped in what is  my role as a school board member what  are the values and vision that we as a  board bring to the district  in addition to the trustees  superintendent dr jesus jarrah would  also be invited to take part now this  proposal will be discussed at the  upcoming school board meeting on  november 30 at five o'clock